[music]
>> I'm sure that sometime in the last few
hours most of you did this. You typed a
request into a small box to a super
intelligence and then you waited.
You watched the cursor blink, maybe a
little throbber cycled through clever
gerunds like hullabalooing, tomfoolery,
and philosophizing
to hide the wait. Maybe it gave you what
you wanted, maybe you rephrased it and
tried again.
It all felt completely normal. I want to
spend the next 20 minutes making
prompting feel unfamiliar and strange
again. I'm Ted Johnson, co-founder of
Join an AI.
During my 25-year career building
enterprise software, collaboration
systems, and AI-enabled interfaces, I've
always focused on human interaction.
I've also been following AI
for two decades, including back to the
far less impressive GPT-1 and 2. And
when ChatGPT arrived, I felt two things
at once. First, and unsurprisingly,
amazement, knowing the world would never
be the same, followed by actually
surprising disappointment I couldn't
shake. This disappointment turned into
an observation that started a company,
Join an AI, and that I keep coming back
to, which is why do we still have to
learn AI? Why does something this
powerful
so often feel unnatural to use? Here's
the path we'll take to answer that.
We'll start with the most familiar
computer interface and make it strange
again. Then, I'll give you three key
concepts.
The channel, the physical transport that
carries your intent,
expression, the range and richness of
meaning the channel can carry,
and the protocol, the shape or rules of
this exchange. I'll use those three
concepts to show you that the prompt is
our present-day punch card. We'll share
examples of the ways interfaces could
progress, and we'll wrap with some
practical advice for AI and
human-centered design.
Everyone knows what this is, the
keyboard.
It's everywhere and it feels completely
normal or natural.
But it isn't. We all had to take
lessons.
We all had to practice.
And I say this is someone who loves
keyboards.
But it seems that we've been trying to
fix them as long as they've been around.
People have tried more efficient layouts
like the Dvorak or Colemak to save their
fingers some work. A more extreme
example, some keyboard enthusiasts
refuse to squander their two digits on
the spacebar giving them four or eight
or 10 keys
to press with that efficient thumb of
theirs.
And what do we even mean by the
keyboard? Here's the patent drawing for
the layout we use every day. This
patent's from about 1860.
And my personal favorite, it just as
could have easily been the Hansen
Writing Ball, which looks anything but
like a way you want to talk to a
superintelligence.
We carry these legacies of an arbitrary
input device designed under constraints
that haven't existed for a century.
And we put it between ourselves and the
most capable machines ever built. Nobody
alive chose it. We all inherited it. And
then we stopped noticing. So, that's the
first idea, the channel. The medium an
interface gives you to work in. A
keyboard is a channel. A microphone,
channel. A screen, a punchcard, a prompt
box, all channels. And channels matter
because each one can physically carry a
different kind of signal. For example,
text is a stream of discrete symbols.
Voice can carry timing, pitch,
hesitation, and words. A diagram can
carry spatial relationship all at once.
But these are differences in what the
medium can transmit. It's bandwidth, not
the differences in the meaning. And
carrying more signal isn't the same as
the machine understanding [snorts]
any of it. That's a separate question.
That's the next idea. Humans use all
these channels constantly without
thinking. We never pick one channel and
force everything through it. That would
be absurd. And yet, that's what we ask
people to do with machines over and
over. Hold on to the word channel
because here's the plot twist. With AI,
the channel never really changed.
You're still typing into a box, but what
you were allowed to push through it was
about to. For the first time, the
computer channels carry rich, complete
human language. Notice I said what it
carries, not what it is. You're still
typing into a box, you're still hitting
the submit button. The keyboard didn't
change. What improved is the range of
what you're permitted to express through
it. There's the second idea, expression.
How much of what you actually
communicate or mean will go through the
interface? That's the second idea,
expression. How much of what you
actually communicate or mean will the
interface let through? Here's an example
of expression progress over time with
computers.
Starting with assembly, which gave you
an instruction set, a few dozen opcodes.
Then came the commands with the shell
inputs, flags. Then modern programming
languages gave you primitives that you
could compose. While powerful,
step-by-step, each one of these is a
fixed vocabulary, requiring you to
express your intent by choosing from a
menu the machine will accept.
Natural language blew that menu open.
For the first time, you can say almost
anything, the way you'd say it to
another person.
And on the expression one axis, the leap
is real and enormous. There's an ocean
of meaning in an ordinary human request,
context, nuance, intent, all things
we've never had to spell out to each
other. For the first time, you can say
almost anything the way you'd say it to
another person. For the first time, a
machine can take it in. So, here is what
should bother us as engineers and
designers as it's bothered and inspired
me. The channels for computers have been
the same for 15 years, some 180 years.
Now, with AI, we've poured an ocean of
expression into it. So, why does it feel
like we're still sipping through a straw
and struggling to learn how the AI
thinks?
Because there's a third idea
underpinning the other two, and it's
really the one that hasn't kept up, the
protocol.
The rules you follow and the shape of
the interaction itself.
Channel stayed the same.
Expression exploded in the last 3 years
with LLMs, but the protocol, prompting,
is the protocol of a punch card. And the
punch card's protocol is good old batch.
Here's what punch card batch meant. You
sat down away from the machine,
carefully encoded your entire request in
advance, carried your deck to the
operator, you submitted the job, and
then you waited, sometimes hours,
sometimes overnight.
Then you read the printout, found one
thing that was wrong, fixed it,
resubmitted it, and waited again. The
machine never engaged with you while you
were thinking.
It engaged with the finished package
after the fact. Now, let's look at the
prompt. Assemble the whole request,
submit it, wait, read what comes back.
Something's off, assemble it again,
submit it again, and wait. We have to
acknowledge that there are features,
interactive features improving this. You
can ask for updates, you can ask for
summaries of what was done.
But in the end, it's still batch with
interactive sprinkles. It's the same
protocol.
We shrank the wait time from overnight
to a few seconds or few minutes, and the
speed fooled us into thinking that it
become interactive. It hasn't. It's
still batch. You still package a
complete turn before the machine is
allowed to participate. We learn tricks,
send tips to use
code skills, or rewrite prompts a
certain way to manage this. And speaking
doesn't change it. Your voice just gets
transcribed into the box and submitted.
Shorter batch is still batch because the
protocol is the part that did not
advance. The protocol is the part we've
had to learn. We just gave it a
flattering name. We call it prompt
engineering and treat it like it's a
power user skill. Strip the label off
and it's a set of rules for packaging up
good old batch. For example, tell it to
think step-by-step. Give it examples.
Ask it to be an expert. Don't ask it to
be an expert.
Don't ask it that way. Paste more
context. Paste less context. Only talk
to it through markdown documents. We
trade incantations. We've learned the
magic words. That's the illusion. It
feels like mastery, but it's the same
sort of mastery a punch card operator
had. Knowing exactly how to assemble the
deck so the job wouldn't fail. Moreover,
we've gotten good at prompting or these
black boxes. And and that's the part
that should bother us, not reassure us.
None of this means prompts are bad.
Punch cards weren't bad. Command lines
aren't bad.
They're brilliant solutions for
constraints of their time.
But that's the whole question. Is batch
still the right protocol?
Are we still pre-packaging our intent
for a machine that no longer needs us to
because it shouldn't need us anymore?
It can ask a follow-up. It can clarify
mid-thought. It can notice it's missing
something and say so. It should be human
conversational. Sherry Turkle at MIT
puts it very well. Conversation is the
most human and humanizing thing we do.
It's one of humanity's superpowers. The
capacity to engage and think is right
there. And yet,
we're still making people submit the
deck and wait for the run. Even the
punch card inheritance protocol in fact,
batch came from the weaving loom. You
set the whole pattern in advance, then
ran the cloth. The punch card got reused
on computers by default. We're still
standing at the same moment again.
AI could finally meet us in the middle
of a thought,
got handed a protocol of a loom. That's
what I mean. The prompt is still a punch
card, not because of how you encode it.
The encoding is powerful and awesome.
Because
when the LLM is allowed to engage only
after you've packaged a complete turn
and submitted it. And this is where the
mismatch bites. Model capacity is
shooting straight up. Reasoning, speech,
vision, memory, planning, all curving
upwards. The interface protocol, flat.
Still a box, still a submit button,
still the human doing all the work
around the LLM. The human still decides
what context matters, still remembers
what to ask, still chooses the timing,
still notices the ambiguity, still
repairs the output, still has to
carefully engineer a prompt. But the
intelligence feels magical.
It's the interface that still feels like
work. And when it feels like work, when
the output's wrong, when the magic words
don't land, people blame themselves.
They decide they're bad at this. They're
not specific enough. They don't get AI.
I want to say as clearly as I can, it is
not our fault. We are not bad at using
AI. We are being asked to operate a
brand new kind of intelligence through a
protocol of a punch card. The mismatch
isn't the user, it's the interface. In
the race to enable AI, we shortcut the
interface.
Okay, let's make this concrete and
familiar. A few weeks ago, my co-founder
was using a Frontier company's voice
mode.
These are known as speech-to-speech
models.
He asked it a normal question, "When is
the next Timberwolves game?" Fine. It
answered it quickly. Then, he pretended
I showed up as if to speak to me and
said,
"Hey Ted, come on in." He wasn't talking
to the AI.
But these models have no way to know
that.
So the AI did the only thing a prompt
box can do. It took his speech as a turn
and answered it.
"Sure, I'm here. What's on your mind?"
That's not a good answer, but it's not a
dumb model.
It answered the first question
perfectly, but it's a protocol with
exactly one slot. Your message, then
it's reply. It has no concept of who's
speaking, whether the words were even
meant for it. And the frontier companies
want to make strides as well. OpenAI
released GPT real-time 2 in late May and
started trying it for their voice mode
as well. It backchannels now. It goes,
"Mhm." and right.
The little sounds we make to show we're
listening actively. We're seeing the
field is converging on the same
conclusion we built our company on. The
interface has to stop being batch and
start participating. Others are working
on real-time conversation as well.
This is Nvidia's Personal Plex, a
research model, not ours.
Watch what happens when it gets
interrupted.
>> I've been thinking about starting a
diet.
>> Yeah, starting a diet can feel a bit
daunting, but you could keep it simple.
Focus on eating more veggies and fruits.
Try to
>> Before I forget, I signed up for a
marathon.
>> All right, congrats on signing up for
the marathon. That's a big challenge.
You've got a lot of time. Focus on
building a solid base with regular long
runs. Stay hydrated. Make sure you fuel
right before and after, and don't forget
to stretch and take care of your feet.
>> Personal Plex stops. It yields. It picks
the thread back up. That's real turn
taking, listening and speaking at once
in real time.
>> You need to come visit me.
>> Oh, okay.
>> go into the city.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz that's the thing, like
there's like the random spray paint, but
then there's also like
I'm not sure. People must commission
them. Like these massive like mural
spray paint pieces.
>> Yeah, I think they do.
>> And Persona Plex's back channels listens
and lands where a person's would.
Beyond conversational flow, there are
lots of challenges and it's a complex
problem. Making listening noises is not
really the same as knowing who's in the
room.
These are not trained to tell that "Hey
Ted" wasn't meant for it.
But we are. We're working on improving
the protocol to the models.
By giving it a better understanding of
human and group conversation.
>> Good afternoon, everyone.
>> Good afternoon, Sam.
>> Hi, Jordan.
>> Good afternoon. Good to see you both.
>> Quick one, which requirement is this? Do
we have an ID?
>> This is our Q442, expense approvals.
>> There, it answered a question.
It only takes actions based on the
utility-driven model.
So, it creates goals to fulfill as it
labels each of the participants'
statements as a question, a proposal, an
answer, and then only takes a turn when
no one else is speaking or holding the
floor.
>> Right, we need users to approve requests
faster.
>> Yeah.
The approval flow's too slow.
>> What kind of requests, though?
>> Expense approvals first.
Access requests eventually.
>> AI, hold that.
>> Actually, let's pause. Expense approvals
or a general approval workflow?
>> Expense approvals first release.
>> Access requests are future scope.
>> That changes the data model.
Good to know.
>> AI, pull that up for everyone.
>> Tracking determining who's the speaker
is referring to is critical. In this
case, it was easy with a direct
reference to the AI, but it will happen
again without a direct reference.
>> Oh, I'd forgotten that was a rule.
>> So, over 5,000 needs a second approver?
>> Yep. Manager plus finance.
>> So, a big one can't be a single tap.
>> Right. Over the limit, it routes to a
second approver.
>> Agreed. Under five, one tap's fine.
>> Works for me.
>> Okay.
Agreed.
Expense approvals, 5,000 threshold.
>> Right there, the AI resolved the scope
objective. No one wrote the prompt, no
one patched the turn and hit submit. The
system was in the conversation,
following it, understanding, and
choosing its moment.
>> AI, capture that for us.
>> First release supports expense approvals
only. Access requests are out of scope.
Managers can approve or reject an
expense right from a notification.
And per the finance controls policy,
anything over $5,000 routes to a second
approver?
>> Actually, make the threshold 10,000, not
five.
>> Want me to update the requirement to a
10,000 threshold?
>> Yes.
>> AI, is this room free after the meeting?
>> Let me check. The room looks free until
3:00, but yes, it's yours until 3:00.
>> And that's the difference
between a smart machine behind the same
old prompt and an interface that finally
participates.
Here's the mindset shift I want to leave
you with. AI is not just an intelligence
technology. It's increasingly becoming
an interface technology. And if so,
then book smart models alone are not
enough.
Stop picturing AI as a smarter machine
hiding behind prompts, agents, loops,
and all the old paradigms. We have to
start seeing intelligence itself as a
thing that can finally remove interface
constraints and amplify human potential.
For 75 years, humans adapted to the
machine. It's syntax, it's forms, it's
timing, it's batch. A system that can
reason, listen, infer, adapt should be
able to meet us partway, if not all the
way.
Instead, if AI is for users, then we
should obsess about maximizing the
interface. So, then the design question
changes. It needs to become what burden
are we still putting on humans only
because the machine used to be too
limited to carry that burden itself. Ask
that question,
and the whole interface space opens up.
The answer isn't always chat. It isn't
always voice, and not a wall of
markdown. It's definitely not a
decade-old set of digital constructs.
The right answer is the affordance
humans already use with each other.
Communication, a question, a pause, a
sketch, a checklist, a quiet aside, or
saying nothing at all.
An interface where timing and modality
aren't the humans' job anymore.
Where choosing the right channel at the
right moment is done by the AI. And as a
usability person,
this is the part that excites me the
most. When you take that burden off
people, the the disappears and adoption
follows.
Computing has mostly been about to date
improving how humans encode their intent
for machines. The punch card, type a
command, click a menu, use your thumb on
an iPhone, write a prompt. Every step
was progress and every step carried the
old constraint forward into the next
era. A translation tax, a precision tax,
context tax, repair tax. AI is our
chance to put those down.
Not by making everything magical. Not by
making everything voice. Not by
replacing human judgment, but by making
computers for once
more fluent with us. Most talks and
videos cover how to use or adopt AI.
The deeper question is how AI
intelligence changes the interface.
Human conversation is the most human
thing we do.
Because if a machine can finally
understand more of what we mean, then we
can and should stop reshaping ourselves
to be understood by it.
Thank you.